I talk to a lot of people and there's
one thing in common so many of the
people I talk to say like oh yeah my dad
got me starting the business or my mom
got me starting the business now you
don't have any family in the business
family hates the business yeah yeah
they're like you should have been a coal
miner yeah
loser he'd have been a good coal miner q
you posted a picture of your dad and he
looks like a tough guy
he sounds exactly how he looks he talked
like this
he doesn't gain and when he works on a
train he says that's kind of her he's
not just hanging out by a train he's a
train conductor he he always says I own
cocaine like Casey Jones or whatever
that song is and I don't know I hope
he's not high on cocaine that would be
dangerous yeah well you just got him in
a lot it's a good scientist in this cup
he's not very supportive of that he
can't get over the fact that I have to
wear makeup yeah yeah it's a big hurdle
for him he's like I'm like I've booked
this new gig it's very exciting he's
like you still wearing makeup though and
why do you sound more and more like
Macho Man Randy Savage every time we
talk is he he's not impressed at all I
mean you've had all this success and you
work around these movie stars he doesn't
get impressed by any of it uh no I mean
he was in prayer I did a movie
this past summer they called the intern
that's gonna come out in October with
the one and only Robert De Niro yeah and
and so he was pumped on that and I'm
like I'm doing this movie with Robert De
Niro and he's like Abed Robert De Niro
doesn't wear makeup
it does she definitely guys you have to
wear how I would look so horrible
I'm wearing so much makeup right now I'm
gonna look like the you are pretty
you're I am wearing or makeup in anymore
I feel like my face is just I'm gonna
look like a Saint Bernard of a human
however I guess I wore a makeup because
you can see when I'm not wearing makeup
I have some light freckling and then you
can see the veins in my body yeah
sometimes you can see memories
[Applause]
only the sad ones come out though and
he's like oh my god that how you
discover the poor dogs ooh hey thanks
for watching be sure to click subscribe
to see even more great Conan clips you
may now return to your pirated movies
and creepy Japanese pornography